[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition des matins du sénat
poursuivre aujourd'hui l'audition
d'adrien taquet le secrétaire d'état à
l'emploi
fin janvier un reportage diffusé sur m6
dans zone interdite a révélé les
défaillances de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
on parle de l'insalubrité des lieux
d'accueil de la pénurie d'éducateur ou
voir même de prostitution et de viols
entre enfants en réaction adrien taquet
a demandé aux préfets dans les trois
mois un état des lieux de la manière
dont ces établissements sont gérés
direction la salle médicis pour suivre
cette audition préparer pour public
sénat aujourd'hui par alice bardot est
louée molliet saab est ravi d'être
devant vous ce matin je remercie le
président mi longs que l'organisation de
cette audition effectivement que nous
avions programmé je vous ai vu en mars
dernier j'étais nommé depuis à peine à
peine deux mois et à l'époque j'avais
déjà je pense dressé ce que serait
l'année 2019 et les trois gros chantiers
à ces structures en de mon action pour
l'année 2019
j'avais parlé de pacte pour l'enfance
avec trois piliers deux que j'ai
mentionné rapidement ce que ça fait pas
l'objet central de cette audition
aujourd'hui mais j'y reviendrai si vous
le souhaiter évidemment au détour de vos
questions le volet prévention de mon
action avec cette idée que protéger les
enfants passent parfois par mieux
accompagner les parents et donc c'est
tout le projet cette démarche qui est
incarné aujourd'hui pour l'essentiel au
travers de ce projet autour des 1000
premiers jours de la vie de l'enfant
avec une commission qui a été installée
par le président de la république en
septembre dernier commission de
scientifique présidé par boris cyrulnik
qui va nous rendre ses travaux au
printemps et ce qui nous permettra d'ici
l'été de présenter ce qui devrait être
la première véritable politique publique
dans notre pays autour des 1000 premiers
jours de la vie de l'enfant
donc il va de la grossesse jusqu'au 2
ans de l'enfant le deuxième pilier de
l'action que j'ai menée qui est encore
en cours et l'actualité
là aussi chaque jour nous le rappelle du
chemin qui reste à faire mais je pense
quelque chose près
avec la parole se libère c'est la lutte
contre les violences faites aux enfants
dans la continuité du plan de laurence
rossignol que je salue qui se
concentrait sur les violences
intrafamiliales nous avons poursuivi ce
travail nous l'avons amplifié et élargie
au delà des seules violences
intrafamiliales ça fait l'objet de la
présentation le 20 novembre dernier à
l'occasion du 30e anniversaire de la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant d'un plan de 22 mesures de
lutte contre les violences faites aux
enfants avec pour idée d'essayer de
protéger les enfants partout et tout le
temps
des mesures de prévention de
sensibilisation des mesures autour de la
prise en considération de la libération
de la parole de l'enfant
les mesures de lutte contre la
pornographie des mesures de lutte contre
la pédocriminalité dans notre pays avec
notamment le durcissement des peines de
deux à cinq ans pour la consultation de
sites pédocriminels et ce qui a pour
effet mécanique et c'est ce que nous
recherchons en réalité que les auteurs
que les personnes qui consultent ce
genre de sites soient automatiquement
inscrit au fichier des agresseurs
sexuels fameux fille ges sachez mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs que jusqu'à
présent ce n'était pas le cas c'était
sur décision du juge et paix dans 50%
des cas les auteurs n'étaient pas
inscrits soit 500 personnes qui donc
pouvait postuler à travailler auprès
d'enfants dans une crèche sans que leur
passé judiciaire puisse être retracés ce
sera désormais terminée et nous lançons
par ailleurs nous lançons par ailleurs
dès cet après midi avec la garde des
sceaux grande mobilisation de l'ensemble
des administrations pour nous assurer
que l'ensemble des administrations et
surtout les établissements qui sont sous
leur sous leur tutelle
et ça vaut par ailleurs pour les
collectivités locales que tout le monde
a bien connaissance de la loi sert de la
nécessité de consulter le fichier est ce
que tout le monde le fait effectivement
ski mon avis est loin d'être le cas
et par ailleurs nous devons garantir à
chacun aussi les conditions effectives
de cette consultation
certaines personnes notamment dans les
établissements de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance nous disent on interroge le
fichier alors pas directement sa passe à
préfecture à chacun individuellement qui
peut consulter un fichier de cette
nature là évidemment et la réponse mais
six mois nous revenir et donc entre
temps on a besoin de personnel donc
l'embauché on croise les doigts très
fort bon ça c'est pas possible non plus
il faut que l'on améliore l'effectivité
de cette consultation du fichier
agresseur sexuel l'éducation nationale
le ministère des sports
à cet égard ont automatisé revue les
procédures ce qu'ils font face chaque
année à des volumes importants de
personnes à contrôler il faut qu'on
s'inspire de cela donc nous lançons une
grande mobilisation à cet égard que la
garde des sceaux
cet après midi voilà mais tout ça n'est
pas l'objet de l'audition l'objet de
cette audition et plus particulièrement
centré sur l'âme la stratégie donc de
prévention et de protection de l'enfance
très brièvement vous dire que cette
stratégie n'est pas la stratégie du
ministre mais la stratégie de l'ensemble
des acteurs nous allons lancer dès mon
arrivée une concertation de trois mois
avec l'ensemble des acteurs donc les
départements évidemment les associations
les associations d'anciens enfants près
de protéger sa des papes l'ensemble des
services de l'état
moi j'avais veiller à ce que la justice
évidemment mais aussi l'éducation
nationale bon la santé les sports la
culture soient mobilisés parce que et
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
je considère qu'on peut être exigeant
avec les autres mais que ça commence par
être exigeant avec soi même et qu'il ya
un moment on ne peut pas indéfiniment
notamment quand il ya des crises qu'elle
soit médiatique ou autre se rejeter les
responsabilités
je pense que chacun doit être au rendez
vous de ses propres responsabilités
la vie d'un enfant elle ne s'organise
pas en fonction de notre organisation
administrative et quand il est question
de
droit à l'éducation ou de droit à la
santé dont il est question de la
pédopsychiatrie sur laquelle je
reviendrai avant que le président nul en
ne le fasse lui-même c'est l'état qui
doit être rendez vous voilà donc il
fallait il était important sa dimension
interministérielle la mobilisation des
autres ministres qu'ils ne prennent pas
à cette concertation concertation de
trois mois six groupes de travail sur
les assistants familiaux sur la question
la qualité de service et de la sécurité
des enfants justement à la question du
handicap gros sujets 30% des enfants de
la zone sont ensuite une reconnaissance
mdph questions de gouvernance
voilà six groupes de travail qui nous
ont remis leurs travaux et donc
dévoilement d'une stratégie de
prévention et de protection de l'enfance
qui a été dévoilée en le 14 octobre 14
octobre dernier
et si vous me permettez
peut-être qu'en cette noble institution
ce sera mal vu mais j'espère vous me
pardonnerez mais peut-être de vous
présenter un peu la philosophie le
contenu très précis de cette stratégie
au prisme 2 ma vision de l'état et ma
vision de l'état et de l'articulation de
l'état avec les collectivités locales
notamment dans des politiques que je
considère partager mais une fois encore
parce que l'état a des responsabilités à
assumer
si vous voulez pour moi les thaïs le
rôle la place de l'état se divise en
trois en trois parties trois strates
d'une part un état stratège pilote qui
fixe les grandes orientations de
politique publique et qui est aussi
garant des droits fondamentaux lors du
du régalien
et à cet égard les loi du 5 mars 2007 et
du 14 mars 2016 sont évidemment des
socles important fonds à ses fondateurs
ont remis un certain nombre de choses à
leur place mais qui nous a semblé
nécessaire de peut-être d'approfondir et
de concrétiser sur certains volets
notamment dans l'affirmation de cette
étape pilote au rendez vous de ses
responsabilités c'est dans cette optique
l'un parce que c'est ce qui nous a juste
petite parenthèse cette stratégie de
prévention et protection d'enfants ce
n'est pas que la contractualisation
vous l'aurez bien compris c'est pour ça
que je me permets d'en bas les plus
larges
on a beaucoup parlé de ça mais c'est
loin de n'être que ça et donc dans ce
cadre d'état pilote c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai annoncé notre souhait de
réformer la politique là le pilotage de
cette politique publique de la
protection de l'enfance le conseil
national la protection de l'enfance doit
être renforcé dans ses missions
peut-être l'occasion d'en débattre tout
à l'heure avec laurence rossignol
notamment mais doit être renforcée dans
cette danse émission peut jouer un rôle
de pilote plus important qu'aujourd'hui
on a aujourd'hui fondamentalement une
situation vous avez beaucoup
d'institutions qui s'occupe de l'enfance
est un constat assez largement partagée
que ça manque de pilotage
donc c'était un problème quelque part et
donc l'idée c'est vraiment de renforcer
ce pilotage avec un modèle je sais pas
du fait un modèle d'inspiration fait mes
anciennes fonctions en tant que député
notamment je sais pas si on arrivera à
saran avec des choses intéressantes à
regarder je trouve côté cns a pour le
handicap et avec l'idée de effectivement
de renforcer le pilotage avec
potentiellement le rapprochement du
giped donc 119 l'observatoire nationale
la protection d'enfance du cnpe l'
agence française de l'adoption pour
ancrer définitivement l'adoption dans la
protection de l'enfance
et puis il ya un sujet dans le sujet qui
la connaît question des connaissances
des données c'est qu'on a très peu de
données sur la protection de l'enfance
donc on a le npa d'un côté on a
l'adresse nous chez nous qui fait quand
même mal de statistiques et d'études
on a les au dpe au niveau départemental
donc l'idée n'est pas du tout de mettre
les eaux des pays sous la tutelle de
fait les choses soient très claires mais
de mieux articuler quand même les au dpe
et le pilotage national parce que les
montées les données viennent des
territoires aujourd'hui à 80 au dpe
quand je suis arrivé il y en avait 50 et
je les perds c'est la loi de 2007
maintenant il faut qu'à l'horizon 2022
on est le dpe dans chaque territoire
il fonctionne bien où les jeunes sont
associés qui anime la politique
territoriale et qui nous fait remonter
des données donc renforcement de la
politique pour le pilotage de la
politique de protection de l'enfance et
puis en pensant mais vous y reviendrez
peut-être parce que ça fait l'objet de
débats enfin les incidences dans le
cadre des discussions sur la loi de
bioéthique mais bien pensé aussi
l'articulation de cette instance avec le
conseil national d'accès aux origines
personnelles de knauf pour votre
information nous avons renforcé les
moyens du giped du 119 400 mille euros
supplémentaires de son bureau qui
viennent de l'état de cent mille euros
qui viennent des départements puisque
c'est une contribution commune
nous avons renforcé les moyens cela a
permis de recruter 5 5 pardon écoutant
supplémentaire de rendre accessibles aux
services aux sourds et malentendants de
développer un forum un site internet
pour démultiplier les canaux de contact
autre vision nationale des choses les
assistants familiaux les familles
d'accueil
je vais être bref profession traverse et
de doutes d'interrogations de
difficultés les profils des jeunes ont
changé plus complexe ils se sentent très
seuls
il ya une il ya une pyramide des âges
très défavorable qui fait que dans
chacun des départements les instants
familiaux partent à la retraite et ils
ont beaucoup de mal à recruter de
nouveaux
des départements où ils sont très
intégrés dans l'équipe départementale et
donc bénéficier de la formation etc
d'autres où il ne participe même pas à
la rédaction du projet pour l'enfant
c'était juste bon donc il ya un vrai
boulot ça faisait l'objet d'un des
groupes spécifiquement de la
concertation nous allons lancer j'ai
annoncé ça au colloque j'aurais
travaillé samedi de l'unafam nous allons
lancer le 27 février prochain des
négociations collectives sur les
assistants familiaux pour revoir les
conditions d'exercice la question
désagréments de la formation la
revalorisation financière statutaire
symbolique de cette profession donc là
aussi négociation collective parce que
c'est de cet ordre là c'est pas l'état
qui décide tout seul avec les syndicats
avec les associations représentatives
là aussi les tailles dans son camp son
rôle dans son rôle par ailleurs vous
évoquiez monsieur le président des
reportages qui pointe un certain nombre
de choses mais peut-être pas forcément
la lumière ou sur les choses les plus
structurantes mais les gens qui
connaissent un peu le secteur et j'y
reviendrai quand on parle de la
pédopsychiatrie identifie bien les
problèmes mais vous le savez
probablement les seuls enfants c'est le
seul secteur je pense peu de choses près
où il n'y a aucune norme de quelle façon
qu'il soit dans les établissements
contrairement à la toute petite enfance
donc côté tout ce qui a trait au taux
d'encadrement aux qualifications à la
formation des professionnels qui sont
dans les établissements tout ça n'existe
pas donc j'ai saisi le conseil national
la protection de l'enfance afin qu'ils
puissent travailler sur le sujet des
normes des taux d'encadrement dans les
établissements et ça je pense que tout
le monde est d'accord sur la nécessité
un peut cadrer les choses les
l'homogénéiser que c'est bien pour tout
le monde à commencer par les enfants
évidemment a donc là aussi l'état dans
son rôle un peu d'impulsions et de
pilotes mais de façon partenariale
évidemment partenariale mais d'impulsion
de choses au niveau national alors on
peut devrait pas faire ça
l'état n'assurerait pas une deuxième
fonction qui est fonction de contrôle
fixer des objectifs des grands principes
des principes fondamentaux il faut vous
assurer de ceux ci sont bien respectés
alors ce sont évidemment les
départements qui sont premiers
responsables du contrôle des politiques
publiques humaine qu'il met en oeuvre et
de l'argent public aussi qui leur parce
que c'est aussi ça l'argent public qu'il
qu'il donne aux partenaires aux
associations auxquelles ils délèguent la
prise en charge de l'accompagnement des
des enfants pour autant l'état vous le
savez a aussi un mission générale de
protection des personnes quand la santé
la moralité la sécurité des personnes
est mise à mal et en danger le préfet
notamment et mission de protéger ces
personnes là mais de façon subsidiaire
le documentaire m'était tendu que vous
évoquez mettait en lumière un certain
nombre de choses que vous saviez que
nous savons par ailleurs dans un
département au mois de décembre un drame
a eu lieu dans un hôtel ou un enfant
hébergés dans un hôtel à tuer un autre
enfant de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
dans les hauts-de-seine
donc là aussi département d'assumer leur
responsabilité à l'état d'assumer les
siennes propres sur ces deux événements
complément de tout le reste j'ai demandé
effectivement au préfet de me remet de
se rapprocher des présidents de
départements et de me remonter sous
trois mois
deux choses quelles sont les procédures
d'alert d'événements indésirables mise
en place par les présidents de
départements
quand il se passe quelque chose ce qui
est une obligation de prévenir le préfet
donc est ce que ces procédures existent
bien et sont elles mises en oeuvre et
par ailleurs quelles sont les
obligations de la loi
par ailleurs quels sont les plans de
contrôle mises en place par les
départements sur leur établissement et
sous trois mois les préfets vont me
remonter tout ça
et nous allons voir si les choses sont
de nature à assurer la sécurité des
enfants parce que c'est de ça dont il
s'agit est en fonction nous établirons
notre propre plan de contrôle s'il ya
des endroits où ça ne semble pas être
satisfaisant c'est notre responsabilité
sachez sur la question des
hauts-de-seine est d'humeur ce que
j'évoquais que j'ai demandé à
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales de mener une mission sur la
politique de l'enfance dans les hauts
seine et sur ce cas en particulier
savoir ce qui s'est passé et au delà de
ça j'ai demandé à l'inspection générale
des affaires sociales de mener une
mission nationale cette fois ci sur le
territoire sur la question des enfants
dans les hôtels c'est un sujet dont on
connaît tous
il n'y a pas que des mineurs non
accompagnés il ya aussi des enfants dits
complexes ou terme terrible enfin
terrible odieux d'incassable on va
bannir de notre vocabulaire
c'est aussi eux ont fini par mettre à
l'hôtel parce qu'on ne sait pas les
prendre en charge
donc moi je veux savoir combien
d'enfants dans les hôtels pourquoi ils
sont là quel est leur profil et qu'on
décide ensemble ce que l'on fait et
qu'on arrête de laisser ce sujet de côté
c'est un sujet complexe ans mais je
pense qu'à un moment il faut qu'on s'y
attellent ensemble et puis elle pardon
et puis à l'état partenariale les un
visionnaire l'état l'état pilote l'état
qui contrôle et l'état partenaire et
dans cette relation avec les
départements en l'espèce sur la mise en
oeuvre de cette politique est une fois
encore partenariat ça veut dire que
chacun doit être au rendez vous de ses
propres responsabilités
hélas une fois encore être exigeant mais
je suis d'abord exigeant avec avec nous
avec l'état c'est une compétence
partagée
j'ai pas de mal à dire que depuis que
l'état a décentralisé cette politique il
a eu probablement tendance à considérer
que c'était plus trop sa compétence à
lui voilà alors que c'est une compétence
partagée
selon moi et on peut pas renvoyer toutes
les difficultés au département voilà
alors c'est la raison pour laquelle sur
des champs de compétences étatiques nous
nous oeuvrons pour améliorer la
situation des enfants
je vais vous prendre deux exemples la
pédopsychiatrie et la santé mentale des
enfants fait 30 ans que la psychiatrie
dans notre pays
délaissée et donc nous en payons les
pots cassés aujourd'hui donc d avant ma
nomination agnès buzyn est présenté à
une feuille de route la santé mentale
avec un certain nombre de mesures
la nomination d'un délégué
interministériel qui est sur ces sujets
pédopsychiatrie mme comme sur les autres
ce que vous avez même chose ça
psychiatrie adulte ça le mental en
prison enfin une enveloppe de 100
millions d'euros dont 20 millions
d'euros ont été fléchés sur la
pédopsychiatrie donc là je suis pas
spécifiquement sur l'aide sociale à
l'enfance je suis surtout les enfants
mais defacto sa bénéficie aussi aux
enfants de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
et puis en prévention aussi 20 millions
d'euros ce qui a permis en décembre
dernier de sélectionner 35 appels à
projets émanant des territoires et qui
vont pouvoir se mettre en oeuvre dès
maintenant création d'une équipe mobile
création de sessad de place de places de
jour en fonction des besoins des
priorités des manques sur les
territoires vous avez un fonds
d'innovation en organisation pour la
psychiatrie de l'enfant et de
l'adolescent qui est doté de 10 millions
d'euros et qui a permis là aussi de
sélectionner parmi un certain nombre de
projets de financer 19 projets pour les
enfants et les adolescents
nous essayons de reconstruire une
filière parce que c'est de ça dont il
s'agit donc ces deux dasa et nous avons
créé 20 postes de chef de clinique en
pédopsychiatrie avec l'idée de pouvoir
avoir un ph part
par faculté donc sacré des internes
externes
ça va prendre 5 6 en sept ans ouais mais
bon il faut bien commencer sur la
question de la santé
plus largement les parlementaires que
vous êtes avaient voté dans le dernier
projet de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale
l'obligation d'un bilan de santé bilan
de santé obligatoire des enfants à
l'entrée à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
avec la création d'un forfait
consultation complexe pour les
professionnels et par ailleurs l'année
dernière nous avons commencé à
expérimenter dans le cadre de l'article
51 du plfss des parcours de soins pour
les jeunes de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
l'expérimentation dans trois
départements de cette année nous
étendons à dix départements bas et en
espérant que l'expérimentation s'avère
pertinente et efficace et que nous
puissions l'étendre à l'ensemble des
départements le plus rapidement possible
sur sept dix départements ces 10
millions d'euros supplémentaires qui
sont investis sur la santé de ces de ses
enfants
et puis il ya le volet
contractualisation dont j'ai alors la
logique était effectivement sur toute
une partie des actions de proposer aux
départements de contractualiser un peu
dans le même esprit que ce qui a été
fait sur la stratégie de prévention et
de lutte contre la pauvreté
avec une différence mon souhait d'éviter
un effet dessous poudrage et donc de
vouloir concentrer les investissements
sur trente départements puis 30
départements l'année prochaine pour
couvrir l'ensemble du territoire avec
une montée en charge budgétaire d'ici à
2022 il y avait un socle il ya quelques
conditions et un socle commun
obligatoires proposée au département les
quelques conditions c'est que le bas
pour contractualiser par exemple il
faudra avoir le dpe qui marche
exemple parmi quelques autres petites
choses qui peuvent permettre quand même
de faire converger et les pratiques
et puis dans les socles obligatoires il
y avait deux choses ont demandé au
département de choses on leur demandait
d'une part dans les projets qui nous
remontent qui est des choses qui
concernent la pmi et un investissement
dans la pmi parce que stratégies de
prévention et de protection de l'enfance
alors envie de réarmer la pmi très
belles institutions auxquelles on n'a
demandé de plus en plus ces dernières
années sans forcément y donner les
moyens de le faire donc il ya tout un
travail par ailleurs qui est fait sur la
paix m et deuxièmement de nous remonter
des projets sur la prise en charge des
enfants en situation de handicap puisque
aussi si vous avez vu le fameux
documentaire la jeune francine qu'on
voit un moment ces déficiences mentales
question que ça soulève n'est pas tant
la question de la formation des
professionnels question formation mais
c'est surtout cette jeune fille ne
devrait pas être là en fait c'est ça le
sujet ça ce qui est dit dans le
reportage mais c'est ça le sujet et nous
devons inventer des formes nouvelles
d'accompagnement de ses enfants parce
que c'est les enfants qui sont au
croisement du social et du médico-social
et quand dans notre pays qu'ils aiment
bien fonctionné en silo vous êtes au
creusement de politiques publiques
bah c'est pas de chance puisque vous
tomber dans le trou entre les deux voilà
il faut qu'on invente les territoires et
il ya des choses qui existent en les
associations invente une forme nouvelle
décloisonner des silos t
d'accompagnement social et médico-social
de ses enfants
voilà donc ça on est puis par ailleurs
il y avait 4 4 grandes grand chapitre
dans la stratégie de prévention de
protection d'enfants c est donc au
département de nous soumettre des
projets mme et donc il ya 62 des pages
écrit à tous les présidents de
départements novembre pour dire voilà on
a bâti cette stratégie ensemble vous
propose de contractualiser on a 80
millions d'euros à m on attend que vous
investissiez de votre côté aussi en
miroir
est ce que ça vous intéresse alors il ya
62 départements qui nous ont répondu
favorablement et pas juste un mail en
disant on veut y aller est vrai dossier
de 5 6 pages avec des projets détaillés
et nous en avons donc choisi 30g annoncé
les 30 lundi dernier les critères de
choix
ça a été bien d'une part l'enfant le
premier critère c'est à là où il y avait
le plus de fragilités de difficultés
d'urgence peut-être et des territoires
dont on sait que certains cumulent
plusieurs difficultés
premier critère le deuxième critère
c'est aussi la pertinence des projets
qui nous était proposé par rapport aux
besoins des enfants et du territoire
voilà quelques exemples que c'est en
alliés dans l'allier pardon un projet de
pardon c'est j'ai dit non pertinence de
certains projets non mais j'ai plus
c'était d'une intervention à domicile
d'entrée système voilier c'est dans la
meuse en plus et la meuse et la meuse
que jamais un programme d'intervention à
domicile
centré sur les 0 6 ans dans la meuse par
exemple voilà est dans la m y avait
quelque chose de très bien dans l'allier
aussi bon voilà donc pertinence des
projets et puis par ailleurs on a veillé
aussi les critères menant à veiller
aussi à voir à la fois des zones
urbaines et puis des zones plus rurales
donc est la creuse les ardennes et puis
par ailleurs banon enfin moi j'avais à
coeur quand même que l'outre-mer
voilà où on sait qu'il ya quand même ça
tombe de problématiques l'outre-mer soit
soit dans la contractualisation et qu'on
puisse aider moi j'ai fait un voyage en
guyane 1 au mois de décembre sur sur sur
le sujet on a commencé à travailler avec
le président du conseil départemental
avec ses équipes
et voilà donc à la guyane et la réunion
qui ont postulé qui sont qui sont dans
la contractualisation et il ya la corse
aussi qui compte voilà
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire d'autre
il ya les quatre départements du nord
aussi voilà il y aura plein de questions
donc mais voilà donc et donc oui je
termine juste pour le calendrier donc
les 30 ont été on sait donc maintenant
l'idée c'est de rédiger les contrats
enfin sert de travailler sur les projets
on va vraiment avoir trente contrats
très personnalisé et très
territorialisée puisque l'idée c'est
vraiment pour chaque territoire voir
comment on peut améliorer la situation
l'idée c'est que d'ici à juin fin juin
ça soit bouclée signé pour que voilà ça
puisse vraiment démarrer concrètement et
l'idée c'est de très vite enchaîné sur
les 32 l'année prochaine pour que d'ici
au 31 décembre de cette année tout le
procès soit fait c'est à la sélection de
la rédaction des contrats et que dès le
1er janvier 2021 l'aca puissent partir
on essaie de rattraper un peu à peu le
temps on va commencer à travailler déjà
sur la sur la prochaine
la prochaine vague voilà il savait pas
dire que c'est pas parce qu'on n'est pas
dans la contractent qu'il n'y a pas de
plein d'autres choses qui se passent par
ailleurs et qu'on il faut pas continuer
à faire des choses bien
voilà en gros ce que j'avais à vous
partager avec vous à ce stade ce matin
merci bien
donc je vous rappelle le ministre va
nous quitter à 10h30 et j'ai pour
l'instant 15 inscrits donc je vais
d'abord 16 maintenant madame de roche
c'est un monsieur le président je vais
faire court
monsieur minutes je suis arrivé au un
petit peu quelques minutes de retard
mais j'ai vu que vous étiez en effet sur
les sujets du fis ges et ça c'est un
vrai sujet est aussi le croisement des
fichiers des départements dans les
agréments où les pertes d'agrément on
s'est aperçu qu'ils n'avaient pas de
remonter et de croisement des fichiers
qui faisait que les familles passer d'un
département à l'autre sur le fige est un
point important il faudrait pas qu'il y
ait possibilité de l'effacer la peine
parce que ça s'est produit dans une
commune de mon département et
malheureusement le la
pearson a continué ces agressions
sexuelles après sans que la commune
puisse être au courant moi je vais
aborder un sujet qui n'est pas vraiment
celui là mais qui est d'actualité qui
concernent le deuil de l'enfant j'ai vu
vous aviez fait des déclarations je vais
pas revenir sur le ce qui s'est passé à
l'assemblée nationale mais j'avais avec
avec le président milan et et de
nombreux membres du groupe déposé en
juillet 2019 une proposition pour
accompagner les familles dans le cadre
des 9èmes proposition travailler avec
avec une association d'un département
qui s'appelle association audrey
ménagers de france et il y avait des les
quatre propositions une qui tenait je
veux que vous l'aviez évoqué à une prise
en charge des frais d'obsèques sous
conditions de ressources
la première c'était une poursuite des
prestations familiales jusqu'au
troisième ans après le décès de l'enfant
ça se fait je crois pour la page mais
c'était pour l'ensemble des promos des
prestations familiales
il y avait un autre point parce que
c'est une expérimentation qui est fait
en maine-et-loire sur la transmission
automatique par lui les services d'état
civil de la ville d'angers du décès de
l'enfant aux allocations aux caisses
d'allocations familiales
ce qui soulage les familles aussi de
cette démarche parce que souvent on leur
dit qu'il y a que ça n'a pas été
transmis on leur fait rembourser les
aides c'est très compliqué et le dernier
point était la gratuité de la
renégociation des emprunts
donc je voulais vous faire part de cette
proposition de loi parce que si un texte
arrive au sénat je souhaiterais pouvoir
greffer préfet ce type de propositions à
moins qu'ils soient adoptées auparavant
voilà je vous remercie merci maintenant
vous êtes 18
madame jouanno merci monsieur le
président je voudrais vous remercier
monsieur le ministre nous avoir tracé en
fait votre feuille de route et je
voudrais vous remercier aussi pour votre
détermination
alors c'est vrai que le reportage de m6
il y a quelques semaines a choqué il été
fait dans cette intention il était
uniquement à charge et il laissait à
penser que tous les départements en fait
se comporter de la même façon ça
et très difficilement apprécié par les
professionnels de la protection de
l'enfance qui sont toujours mais
quotidiennement dans un état de tension
extrême et pourquoi ils sont dans une
tension extrême parce que ces dernières
années on a vu arriver des publics à la
protection de l'enfance qui ont
effectivement des profils très complexe
d'une part des délinquants parce qu'il
faut quand même dire aussi qu'au niveau
de la pjj
on aurait vraiment besoin d'un vent fort
et ses enfants que nous accueillons
aujourd'hui qui sont à la limite du
pénal et qui sont des vrais dangers pour
les autres enfants
en tout cas ne devrait pas être pris en
charge par la protection de l'enfance et
nous le faisons parce qu'il n'ya pas
autre chose et donc l'appui de la pjj
faudrait le renforcer
de l'autre côté vous l'avez souligné 25%
peu près des enfants qui ont un problème
de handicap
évidemment les handicaps ne sont pas
tous les mêmes mais on voit quand même
aujourd'hui que comme nous n'avons pas
de ressources dans les départements en
termes de pédopsychiatrie et bien on se
retrouve un calme et des enfants qui
sont en des compensations et qui devrait
être suivi sur le long terme de façon
médicale et qui ne peuvent pas l'être
et donc on demande à nos professionnels
finalement d'avoir ses compétences
qu'ils n'ont pas et puis le troisième
sujet c'est évidemment la prise en
charge des mn alors sur ces trois feux
les départements ont été mis à mal ont
été mis à mal parce que voilà ça fait ça
fait trop d'un seul coup alors je veux
pas donner d'excusés au département
parce qu'il n'y a pas d' excuses par
rapport à la protection de l'enfant mais
ce qu'il ya c'est que effectivement il
ya des compétences à partager et il ya
aujourd'hui des manques qui sont cruels
donc je vois vous y avez déjà travaillé
en tout cas ce qu il faut c je pense
sans doute avec l'idée de renforcer le
pilotage données avec l'association des
départements de france
l'idée qu'on va fédérer qu'on va animer
et inspiré le travail de la protection
de l'enfance
je pense que ce qui manque finalement
c'est cette espèce d'animation de lancer
enfin sur le plan national
des politiques de protection de
l'enfance alors après je vais un petit
peu m'éloigner de oui je vais
très rapide sur les 1000 jours
je voulais savoir quel rôle de la paix a
mis parce que là ça a été très vite
ébauché mais très franchement
aujourd'hui les pmi se posent des
questions sur leur implication dans tout
ça et puis sur un problème que je
rencontre
comme beaucoup d'autres dans les
départements le syndrome du bébé secoué
alors c'est une question peut-être
comment dirais-je annexes mais en
réalité c'est un vrai sujet dans les
départements on a tous été confrontés à
ça et je crois que une communication
importante et des recommandations de la
haute autorité de santé ont permis de
sensibiliser mais c'est continuellement
à refaire et en particulier auprès des
professionnels de santé auprès bien sûr
des parents mais face à cela je pense
que ces recommandations sont parfois
discutés des affaires ont été portées
devant la justice quel bilan tirez vous
en faites des mesures qui ont été mises
en place et comment on peut aller plus
loin tous ensemble bon je vous remercie
merci monsieur bonne merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre hui merci
pour les présentations la présentation
du plan de l'état
je suis un peu surpris quand même on a
l'impression d'une recentralisation
total de la protection de l'enfance est
alors comme nous sommes assez nombreux
là comme un ancien président de
département ou vice président en charge
des affaires sociales
je voulais en dire un mot et vous dire
que aujourd'hui effectivement dans
l'article qui a été fait l'émission qui
a été fait sur m6 on a pris quelques cas
très particulier et à la limite c'est un
travail journalistique habituel qui fait
qu'on prend les cas les plus
horrible si l'on peut dire et on ne
montre pas tout le travail qui est fait
par ailleurs je crois aussi que les
présidents de départements qui ont
répondu ont répondu presque en disant on
va tout de suite mettre en action
une mesure de contrôle or c'est pa sak i
love et j'aurais pas répondu ça à leur
place j'aurais plutôt dit voilà ce que
nous faisons aujourd'hui et les
difficultés qu'on a effectivement pour
contrôler tous ces établissements
parce que pour l'avoir vécu pendant pas
mal de temps et je crois que mes
collègues et anciens collègues le
comprendront aujourd'hui les
responsables de la protection de
l'enfance sont le président du
département et les la justice l'état
n'intervenait que dans la mesure où il y
avait la pédopsychiatrie qu'il pouvait
effectivement aider mais l'état
n'intervenait pas plus la justice qui
normalement n'est que subsidiaire
d'après la loi de 2007 n'a pas n'a pas
rempli le rôle qu'on attendait d'elle
c'est à dire qu'elle a toujours été en
avant par rapport aux décisions qui ont
été prises pour les enfants et le
président du département n'était souvent
la queue pour payer le placement de
l'enfant et non pas intervenir
directement auprès de l'enfant pour
suivre ce son devenir
je crois que c'est là toute la
difficulté comment voulez vous qu'un
président de département ou enfin où ses
services puissent contrôler un
établissement dans la mesure où soleil
ne sais même pas où est placé l'enfant
pas toujours et que c'est le juge qui a
la main uniquement pour la suite de ce
qui est fait pour cet enfant
donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui vous
proposer de renforcer le contrôle
ce contrôle il doit être beaucoup plus
effectif effectivement dans les
départements mais donnons peut-être
vraiment la responsabilité aux
présidents de départements de s'occuper
des enfants qui lui sont confiés
et puis
[Musique]
peut-être modifiant un peu la façon de
prendre en charge ces enfants on n'a
aucune évaluation j'ai essayé de
raccourcir mais on n'a aucune évaluation
qui a été fait aucune évaluation
crédible qui a été fait ni par les
services de la das ni par ceux du
département de toutes ces années et on
ne sait pas si l'argent considérable qui
est dépensé au niveau des départements à
une efficacité suffisante
vous parlez de 80 millions d'euros qui
seront répartis entre 30 départements
j'ai calculé ça fait à peu près 2 me en
5 euros par département un département
comme le mien qui représentait à peu
près un centième c'était 100 millions
d'euros qui étaient dépensés chaque
année pour la protection de l'enfance
donc les sommes sont considérables et
l'efficacité on n'est absolument pas
certain qu'elle soit réelle donc c'est
en cela je crois qu'il faut modifier les
choses ou revenir au système de la dass
et des enfants de la das ou essayer de
voir avec des départements qu'elle
serait vraiment les possibilités qu'ils
ont pour s'en occuper
merci je vais passer la parole à
monsieur le ministre qui il souhaite 3 3
par 3 vous vous mettez vous mettez trois
minutes 30 par intervention il y en a 20
ça fait une heure d'intervention il y
aura pas de réponse du ministre monsieur
le ministre vous avez la parole
bon alors je vais essayer d'être rapide
risque d'être un peu d'air mais madame
des recherches sur les agréments fichés
sur le très rapidement sur la question
des fichiers désagréments extra ce sera
dans le cadre cette question là noté en
pause et ce temps familiaux ce sera dans
le cadre de l'ouverture des négociations
collectives sur les assistants familiaux
on a bien ce sujet en tête qu'ils aient
connue depuis un certain nombre de
cancers
à cette occasion là qu'on veut le relais
je passais un fichier national là la
solution d'autres solutions mais on va
s'attaquer effectivement ce sujet là et
revoir la question les conditions
d'agrément sur la question du fij sg
entendu votre votre point et sur le
alors sur le deuil de l'enfant oui merci
de nous avoir l'avait identifié mais
votre la lumière sur votre proposition
doit coûter en deux mots que vous dire
là dessus je vais pas forcément revenir
sur la semaine dernière je vais plutôt
me projeter sur les jours et les
semaines à venir et même ce qui a
commencé hier c'est à dire que
maintenant l'idée je pense partagé par
tout le monde et ça a été exprimé aussi
sur les bancs de l'assemblée nationale
hier à commencer par le rapporteur
bricout lui-même l'idée maintenant c'est
de voir comment on saisit l'occasion
d'imaginer de bâtir une réponse
d'accompagnement global pour autant que
faire se peut soulager ces familles
confrontées à un tel drame
voilà alors c'est la raison pour
laquelle des parlementaires des députés
qui aussi avait travaillé de leur côté
notamment sur la question des frais
d'obsèques ou du capital décès
s'agissant de sereno bones continue à
travailler
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
reçu au ministère des solidarités de la
santé avec muriel pénicaud lance une
grande partie certain nombre
d'associations dizaine d'associations
qui accompagnent les familles
confrontées au deuil pour qu'elle voie
là elle partage avec nous leurs
expériences dans l'expertisé qu'elle
nous qu'elle nous donne un peu quelles
pourraient être les solutions très
concrètes
parce que c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il ya
dans votre proposition de loi recoupent
largement ce qui a été évoqué hier et on
voit que c'est souvent des petites
choses très concrètes et qui sont pas
très compliqué à résoudre mais qui
peuvent vraiment soulagé une fois encore
autant que faire se peut la vie des
familles on va recevoir aussi les
partenaires sociaux tout à l'heure parce
qu'il ya la question de l'allongement du
congé de petits finances ça franchement
en vrai il n'y a pas de sujet ni
d'inquiétude
1 alors on va trouver et puis il ya tout
ce qui est autour frais d'obsèques
accompagnement psychologique
accompagnement social groupes de paroles
soutien des associations sur les
territoires bon voilà donc c'est dans
cette démarche maintenant collective
constructive est vraiment avec le
souhait d'apporter une solution famille
et de la porter rapidement vite qu'elle
se sent dans leur quotidien très
rapidement que l'on s'inscrit et donc la
proposition de loi bricout a été
inscrite sauf erreur au à l'ordre du
jour du sénat du 3 mars prochain
donc ce sera l'occasion
voilà deux d'essayer de bâtir sa le
gouvernement apportera probablement des
amendements
et puis il y aura des débats avec les
sénateurs ont vraiment l'occasion
d'évoquer le sujet voilà madame doisneau
sur le reportage vous avez raison de le
dire j'ai j'aurais dû le dire et je m'en
excuse
il faut être intransigeant avec les gens
de situations qui sont montrés et pour
autant il faut évidemment pas réduire
l'aide sociale à l'enfance ase seca et
l'aide à l'enfance dans notre pays sauf
aussi des milliers d'enfants tous les
ans et c'est aussi des milliers de
professionnels engagés qui rendent cela
possible
voilà et il faut le dire vous avez
raison de le dire et d'ailleurs en
réaction à ce reportage il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup
quelques anciens enfants protégés qui
ont pris la parole pour dire mais ce
n'est pas que ça moi ça m'a sauvé la vie
et c'est sur la pjj est sûre j'ai oublié
de mentionner question enfin ça répond à
une évolution
on va mettre en place sur les
territoires des instances quadripartite
avec procureur pjj département et
président du tribunal pour que y est
meilleure animation territoriale
meilleure coordination entre ces
instances pour essayer notamment de
réduire les délais c'est un peu ce qui
évoquait aussi monsieur boom réduire les
délais d'application des peines vade pas
les balles des peines par donc six mois
des mesures
excusez moi pour le lapsus malheureux
malheureux les mesures voilà parce
qu'effectivement vous dans certains cas
d
des juges qui prennent des décisions
sans savoir si derrière elles sont des
places et si elles sont les gens voient
la mise en place des instances quoi
departed pour qu'ils aient davantage
d'échangés d'informations et que ça
fonctionne que ça fonctionne sur les
1000 jours rapidement sur la pmi la pmi
aura un rôle important à jouer dans le
cadre des mille jours ce sera un acteur
important pas exclusif il ya énormément
de professionnels qui sont en contacts
là et d'instances qui sont en contact
avec la petite enfance aujourd'hui vous
avez pmi vous avez les caf vous avez les
libéraux vous avez des communes vous
avez les départements voilà donc on
n'est plus dans l'idée de créer un
parcours pas de créer de nouvelles
instances qui viendrait rajouter une
feuille au millefeuille mais plutôt de
s'appuyer sur l'existant la pmi par
ailleurs est un sujet en soi il faut
michel perron la député ali khreiss
sauver la les pmi il ya un certain
nombre de choses que vous avez déjà voté
dans le dernier plfss vous avez voté la
base légale qui permet de faire de la
délégation de compétence des médecins de
pmi aux infirmières puéricultrices ce
qu'on a besoin de dégager le temps
médical c'est que je crois 80 % des
médecins de pmi qui était en poste à 2,3
en mai sont à la retraite dans deux
trois ans donc on a un sujet de la
situation médicale d'attractif et de ce
métier là qu'il faut revaloriser qu'il
faudrait valoriser aussi dans les
filières de formation parce que alors
que c'est un très beau métier je pas sûr
que ce soit le métier le plus valorisé
dans des dans les cursus et puis il faut
dégager du temps médical
il ya du temps médical ça passe aussi
par la question des agréments
alors le rapport perd on disait il faut
transférer les agréments du collectif et
l'individuel l'accueil jeunes enfants
aux caf mais sans dire comment
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle avec
agnès buzyn nous avons missionné ligue à
ce jeu là n'aura pour rendre son rapport
dans les semaines à venir dire là si on
doit transférer ses compétences là à qui
on les transfère et à quelles conditions
donc ça c'est en effet ce qu'il faut que
ça soit ça ait du sens je pense que ça a
du sens il faut que techniquement ça
soit évidemment évidemment très solide
et puis une volonté de réinvestir pmi
contractualisation l'état est prêt à
mettre de l'argent dans les pmi et
encourage les départements qui ne le
font pas parce qu'un département qui
investissent beaucoup dans leur permis à
le faire davantage monsieur forissier et
merci monsieur le président est monsieur
le ministre je suis un peu dans la
continuité de mon collègue bernard bonne
page et aussi des responsabilités dans
un département qu'elle département du
rhône qui aujourd'hui à une métropole
donc on est en train de revisiter
l'ensemble des politiques publiques dans
ce domaine alors moi ce qui m'a surpris
la première fois que j'ai organisé dans
cette action où j'ai une très très forte
action parce que j'avais une commune qui
avait le record de la délinquance des
mineurs de l'aide dans l'est de
l'agglomération lyonnaise et je me suis
occupé des établissements pénitentiaires
pour mineurs des centres fermés en fin
de tout tout tout là et y compris de
l'adoption
ce que j'ai remarqué et où j'aimerais
bien que l'action gouvernementale
s'impliquent
c'est quand on est dans une organisation
quand on parle de la jeunesse semi
délinquante près délinquante des termes
que je n'aime pas beaucoup on rentre
dans une complexité énorme
le premier comité de pilotage que j'ai
organisé
j'avais 80 personnes pauvres département
du rhône
parce que on m'avait mis bon voilà il
faut qu'il faut faut que toutes ces
personnes
si c'était en gros on n'a pas de pilote
dans l'avion et je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse non plus comme j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya aujourd'hui de tout vouloir
piloter de paris qu'il faut vraiment que
les départements des deux choses tout
d'abord de pilotage et les moyens
aujourd'hui on peut vous avez fait une
bonne exposé théorique mais qui je suis
au regret de vous le dire on est dans
l'incapacité de l'appliquer sur le seul
terrain tout simplement par manque de
financement et de moyens tous les
psychiatres et hippo temps on n'est pas
les plus mal notés dans le rhône
l'hôpital le vinatier il ya des antennes
départementales dans tous les coins mais
même si on voulait aller au fond des
choses on n'y arrive pas et de grâce
quand vous parlez de taux d'encadrement
je voudrais que ne jouant plus fixé
systématiquement par l'état parce que
quand on fait des travaille avec des
groupes ils ont des difficultés quand on
constituent les groupes
il vous faut quelquefois un encore
demain un encadrant pour 5
quelquefois un pour dix et quelques
points pour 7
ça dépend à la fois de l'encadrant et ça
dépend à la fois aussi des difficultés
du groupe comme maintenant on essaye
d'en toutes lettres comme toutes les
fois que c'est possible de mettre les
enfants handicapés
c'est la stratégie qu'elle partage
complètement en fonction de leur niveau
de handicap avec les enfants qui sans
qu'ils en ont moins
on va dire tout le monde perdra un
handicap ça c'est la réalité des choses
donc là c'est une la première des choses
que je souhaiterais et puis la deuxième
des choses c'est que vous vous parliez
moins de deux théories et plus de
financement merci madame meunier et
merci monsieur le ministre
à vous entendre on se dit que celles et
ceux qui réclamaient un ministère à la
protection de l'enfance avaient raison
parce que depuis un an que vous êtes là
on sent que les le sujet est pris en
compte et que les choses se mettent en
place dans une cohérence une continuité
la vie dit que je salue moi je voudrais
juste que j'ai pas très bien compris la
réponse que vous avez donnée à catherine
des roches sur les fichiers il
s'agissait de vous demander je pense que
catherine c'est ce qu'elle voulait de
faire en sorte que ceux qui emploient
des adultes auprès des enfants soient
assurés que leurs antécédents ne soit
pas entachée par quelconque affaire
d'agression ou de violences sexuelles
donc là j'ai pas trop compris la réponse
que vous avez fait moi je voulais
attirer votre attention sur un phénomène
où un élément un peu récents dans la
protection de l'enfance j'en veux pour
preuve ma visite lundi dernier au centre
maternel sa nuque votre voisin de droite
voit de quoi je parle
la responsable attirer mon attention sur
le fait que les chu la maternité du chu
de nantes
adresse directement des jeunes
accouchées avec leur bébé 2 jours 3
jours et les adresses au centre maternel
vous accueillir un bébé deux jours c'est
pas comme accueillir un bébé de moins de
3 ans est ce que c'est une thématique
ces femmes à la rue enceinte avec
enfants que vous pouvez aussi prendre en
compte dans les différentes mesures que
vous déployez sur la prévention et sur
l'action des enfants et des femmes
puisque justement vous le disiez plus
l'enfant est jeune et plus on
s'intéresse à sa mère et à la relation
avec son parent donc voilà est-ce que
vous pensez
parce que le chu adresse ses bébés et
ses mers au centre maternel par défaut
aussi parce qu'il n'ya pas d'assistant
familial d'assistante familiale
spécialisée ou en tout cas qui s'adresse
à ses très jeunes enfants ses bébés
c'est à la sortie de la maternité est ce
que vous pensez développer peut-être un
axe particulier pour la prise en charge
spécifique de ces très jeunes bébés et
c'est vrai que par expérience les
assistantes maternelles ne sont pas
tellement encline à accueillir des tout
petits bébés parce qu'il ya la relation
avec le parent qui est
à prendre en compte donc parfois le
foncier tout simplement tout bêtement
l'appartement qu'on occupe ou la maison
qu'occupe n'a pas les mètres carrés
suffisant en centre ville ou en
métropole pour pouvoir accueillir ses
bébés voilà donc c'était sur ce focus là
spécialement que je voulais attirer
votre attention sur le reste j'ai pas
franchement de questions je trouve que
les choses vont encore une fois dans la
continuité et en partenariat que je
salue simplement la question c'est
quelles mesures d'évaluation vous avez
pour tout cela parce qu'entre les plans
les stratégies les rapports et
dernièrement donc un rapport qu'on va
attendre pas pour l'igas c'est sur la
pmi comment est-ce que globalement on
évalue tout cela merci merci madame
bonfanti monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre on ne peut
évidemment que se réjouir des annonces
qui qui viennent d'être faites et
investir pour la protection de l'enfance
cependant je voudrais relever quelque
chose qui qui me contrarie un peu il
semble que les mineurs non accompagnés
échappe un petit peu à cette stratégie
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous lui
dise je voudrais savoir si vous
travaillé de concert avec le ministre de
l'intérieur sur ce sujet parce que tant
que les filières de des mineurs non
accompagnés ne seront pas démantelées
les moyens de la protection de l'aide à
l'enfance ne seront pas suffisants et
puis lors de votre annonce qui était mi
octobre un certain nombre d'associations
comme l'unicef avait pointé le manque de
moyens dévolus à cette stratégie est ce
que vous avez pu travailler à nouveau
avec elle et quelle est leur lecture de
cette nouvelle stratégie
merci merci je vous laisse répondre
monsieur ministre sinon je peux
continuer
répond plus rapidement monsieur monsieur
forissier sur le pilotage laisser le
pilotage au département au niveau
territorial oui oui évidemment et
d'ailleurs les au dpe sont l'instance et
moi j'ai juste envie de vous dire il est
temps qu'elle fonctionne c'est la loi de
on est en 2020 c'est un constat que je
fais voilà donc c'est l'instance qui
doit animer territorialement les la
politique de l'enfance et area raison je
vous dis enfin là dessus je vous rejoins
totalement est alors sur les taux
d'encadrement vous avez raison ce que
vous pointez et vous avez totalement
raison
c'est très complexe comme sujet parce
que vous avez raison c'est des réalités
humaines ont raidi et donc donc c'est
difficile de faire d'énormes mais pour
autant d'une part ça se fera avec les
territoires et les professionnels parce
que c'est eux qui savent et qui le
vivent tous les jours et je pense qu'on
peut quand même fixer un cadre
et puis peut-être les éléments de
souplesse nécessaire que les
professionnels pour tout cas c'est dans
cet esprit là aussi je vous rejoins sur
la question des moyens écouter et dans
le cadre de la contractualisation et je
réponds un peu d'anticipation à madame
madame bonfanti et dans le cadre de la
contractualisation souvent là on sait
qu'un peu focaliser sur les 80 millions
d'euros mais par ailleurs vous l'avez vu
sur la pédopsychiatrie et puis je vous
ai pas tort quand on sait que les moyens
c'est important moi j'ai un peu de mal à
rentrer par les moyens je préfère
rentrer par le sens et puis parce que
voilà je pense comme le disait monsieur
baume je pense qu'il faut aussi qu'on
s'interroge sur comment est utilisé
l'argent actuellement
mais voilà il ya aussi je vais pas
parler des 100 des 70 juger des 100
greffiers pour les tribunaux des enfants
que avait annoncé la ministre de la
justice
enfin voila on aurait pu additionnez
globalisé on serait arrivé à plus mais
je pense qu'on essaye en tout cas dans
la mesure du possible de d'investir où
c'est nécessaire
alors sur le contrô les antécédents mam
meunier l'idée c'est effectivement de de
faire en sorte que tout établissement
aux personnes puisque en réalité la
question du fichage s on l'a étendu
aussi aux assistantes maternelles
s'étaient inclinés ces voix là quand
vous confiez votre enfant et nous nous
vous allez pouvoir et alors ça ne
nécessite de voir le modus operendi mais
l'idée est aussi de l'étendre au privé
dans ce cadre là est par ailleurs toutes
les autres structures en contact avec la
petite enfance normalement peuvent
consulter le 20 ans pas normalement
elles peuvent consulter le fichier et je
pense qu'il ya effectivement une
question de mise en oeuvre d'opéra
militer d'effectivité c'est la raison
pour laquelle on avec la garde des
sceaux on mène un audit sur avec tous
les ministères et toutes les structures
qui sont sous leur tutelle de comment ça
se passe et pour faire en sorte que ça
se passe effectivement mais je vous
rejoins sur l'objectif sur les sur les
femmes enceintes
c'est un succès pas dans les femmes à la
rue enceintes ou avec des très très
jeunes enfants
c'est un problème qu'on a qu'on a
identifié sur lequel on a été alertée
sensibilisés par les personnels
hospitaliers notamment dans le 93
mais aussi à paris et puis aussi à
bordeaux je tends déplacement à bordeaux
ils ont aussi quelques quelques quelques
cartes pardon et dans les grandes
métropoles alors notamment sur l'île de
france on a on a mobilisé l'agencé
régionale de santé
voilà l idée de créer des unités
passerelle c'est des dispositifs qui
sont spécifiques pour ces pour ces
publics on travaille avec julien de
normandie sur ce sujet là on n'a jamais
autant créer de place vous le savez sur
ce qui hébergeront d'urgence la
difficulté que l'on a aussi c'est que on
est dans toute une stratégie de 2
de logement d'abord c'est à dire de
personnes qui ont un hébergement
d'urgence
quel que soit leur profil puisse aller
vers du logement plus stable ça soit des
pensions de famille logement social et
que ça ça mais de ce point d'arrivée en
quelque sorte mais un peu par
construction du temps à se se bâtir et
que donc on a les dispositifs d'urgence
qui sont qui sont saturés les gens ne
s'est pas fluide et donc on a beau créer
de nouvelles places on est toujours à
courir après le nombre de places
nécessaires
et puis on travaille aussi avec le
ministère de l'intérieur autour des
statuts parce qu'on a un certain nombre
de femmes qui sont en réalité en
situation irrégulière voilà mes donc il
faut qu'on aussi qu'on règle cet aspect
là du sujet parce qu'il ya de très
jeunes enfants donc ça change un peu
comme les choses mais on est on est
alerté là dessus mais voilà on travaille
que la grèce notamment avec la rs
ile-de-france pour essayer de créer des
dispositifs mais voilà c'est un sujet
qui est en pis encore et encore devant
nous et enfin si les émanations à la
stratégie tout ce qu'on fait je vais
répondre un peu à rebours de votre
question et puis après j'y répondrai
plus direct dans tout ce qu'on fait pour
les mii pour les mineurs on le fait
aussi pour les mineurs non accompagnés
parce qu'ils sont mineurs avant d'être
monde accompagnés sont des enfants comme
les autres donc toute la stratégie
bénéficie aussi aux mineurs non
accompagnés
voilà nous travaillons nous travaillons
je sais que c'était pas la question mais
mais je me permets de le redire non mais
parce que non parce que c'est des
reproches que vous a fait par ailleurs
je le paie leur dire par ailleurs oui
nous travaillons avec le ministère de
l'intérieur
c'est la question du démantèlement des
filières c'est beaucoup et qui
travaillent plus que moi on va passer on
va pas se mentir il ya tout un travail
de démantèlement des filières il ya
aussi un travail d'autre part le moins
sur l'état civil
maintenant pour accompagner ces états
d'origine sur la construction d'un état
civil un peu plus solide peut-être que
celui qui existe parce que ça permet de
de mieux suivre et de mieux identifier
les personnes je pensais la guinée
notamment et nous travaillons par
ailleurs avec le ministère de
l'intérieur là non plus ce n'est pas
totalement votre question mais je vous
le dis quand même dans le cadre des
débats qui entourent l'immigration il ya
quelques mois et nous les débats qu'on a
eu les réflexions qu'on a sur la
question de l'accompagnement à
l'autonomie et l'arrivée à la majorité
pour les mineurs non accompagnés
on constate deux choses d'une part créé
des situations et des pratiques très
hétérogène d'un territoire à un autre
vous et des préfets qui délivre des
autorisations de rester sur le terrain
parce que vous avez des jeunes qui sont
dans des filières d'apprentissage qui se
lèvent le matin qui apprennent le
français en six mois et que les
entreprises locales dont qu'une envie
c'est des embauches et enfin se veut le
dire ça et vous avez dans certains
territoires des autorisations de
territoire de rester sur le territoire
qui sont délivrés d'un an trois ans
assez rapidement et dans d'autres
territoires c'est un mois ou deux mois
en fait ça ne sécurise pas du tout les
jeunes et non plus les employeurs
je ne peuvent pas les embaucher alors
qu'ils aimeraient le faire donc à une
circulaire qui va partir et la deuxième
chose qu'on constate c'est que les
départements que ça se passe bien c'est
souvent quand on anticipe la situation
il ya un des partants jaurès et le val
d'oise sauf erreur il ya passé une
convention préfecture département pour
qu'il ya 17 ans se met autour de la
table on regarde la situation du jeune
celloises bon enfin on regarde la
situation du jeune la trajectoire dans
l'acte d'intégration dans laquelle il
est et on me déciderai à 17 ans mais
quand même on sait à peu près ce qui va
se passer à 18 ans et ça enlève aussi
l'épée de damoclès même si c'est pas une
décision par anticipation au dessus de
la tête du jeune et ça évite les
ruptures à 18 ans vous avez souvent en
plus trois mois de rupture pour
l'obtention des papiers le jeune qui
pendant trois mois et rien faire et
parfois son apprentissage eux doit
s'arrêter et donc à une circulaire qui
va partir à tous les préfets pour que i
les harmonisations des pratiques et
anticipation des situations d'accord
eh bien on va regarder madame la
sénatrice
on va regarder voilà merci madame riche
et monsieur le ministre le département
du cher a eu l'honneur d'être retenu
parmi les 30 relais 30 départements
le président michel autissier a et s'est
engagé avec l'adf je crois vous avez des
échanges avec lui 1 concernant
l'inclusion de l'enfance en danger moi
je viendrai je reviendrai sur trois
points assez brièvement puisque ils ont
aussi été évoqués dans mes échanges avec
le président michel haute ici on nous
interrogeons sur le décloisonnement du
champ sanitaire et du champ
médico-social pour résoudre
collégialement les situations complexes
en effet ça nous apparaît plus que
nécessaire et indispensable
cette chaîne médico psycho social
formalisé équivalente un peu à une
chaîne des secours permettra une
réactivité non seulement en journée mais
surtout en fin de soirée et la nuit
alors que ce n'est pas communément admis
que pensez vous de la proposition d'
actes et sur un formulaire cerfa produit
par la cpam le remboursement de
l'intervention d'un psychologue soit en
cas d'urgence comme cela se fait
couramment pour les médecins
généralistes
ensuite nous avons évoqué la
problématique des recrutements des
familles d'accueil qui reste un vrai
sujet dans le cher comme d'autres
départements nous avons 230 familles
alors qu'il en faudrait 2 170 dans le
rapport plusieurs pistes sont
préconisées je vais noté de vous poser
cette question est ce qu'une étude à
l'échelle nationale auprès des familles
d'accueil a été conduite pour
reconnaître les freins au delà du besoin
d'être prêt d'être présent auprès de
l'enfant h/24 et de l'impact sur la
cellule familiale je crois avoir retenu
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé d'une
concertation d'une étude à partir du 27
février
voilà je voulais avoir confirmation que
les départements étaient bien associer
pour le coup enfin nous savons tous que
le nerf de la guerre et budget j'ai lu
dans le rapport que les
le budget supplémentaire attribué au
département n'impacterait pas le pacte
de cahors je voudrais en avoir
confirmation parce que on peut demander
des projets structurants département
mais les finances comme vous le savez
comme s'est répétée à l'envi sont quand
même contrainte
et puis j'ai un message à vous faire
passer confirmez vous votre venue dans
le département du cher
courant mars merci monsieur amiel oui
très rapidement certains sujets que je
voulais aborder ont déjà été abordées
donc juste un coup de projecteur
vous avez cité un mot qui me paraît un
mot clé c'est le mot milieu ouvert et ça
me fait part a dit cependant penser
évoqué l'articulation que vous avez
aussi évoqué entre la ze et la pjj
autrement dit entre des enfants en
danger et des enfants qui deviennent
dangereux lesquels sont de toute façon
en danger or cette question pourrait se
poser tout aussi bien bien sûr à madame
b loubet on a l'impression que la
réponse apportée à la justice des
mineurs se borne à ouvrir des centres
éducatifs fermés dont je ne nie pas
l'utilité au demeurant mais cette
réponse me paraît un petit peu
réductrice et je rebondis sur le mot que
vous avez employé de milieu ouvert aussi
bien dans la ze que de la pjj pour dire
à quel point il me semblerait
souhaitable de développer cette approche
même si bien sûr elle est plus compliqué
la deuxième question a été évoquée aussi
la pédopsychiatrie et je ne m'étendrai
pas le rapport que nous avions fait
alain milon et moi même sur le sujet
avait fait un certain nombre de
préconisations
donc soit dit en passant fort peu ont
été suivis et bien sûr c'est dommage
mais la pédopsychiatrie faut pas avoir
peur de dire que c'est un milieu qui est
complètement sinistré en france
sinistrée le mot le mot n'est pas trop
fort
troisième point vous l'avez évoqué l'
adoption
envisagez-vous à terme une vraie réforme
de l'adoption
qui permettrait peut-être que des
enfants en danger des enfants confiés à
la ze qui vont d'assistante familiale à
emplacement puissent être prises en
charge dans le cadre d'une adoption et
quatrième point l'assistante au niveau
des assistantes familiales
quel type de revalorisation envisagez
vous pour ce métier j'ai exercé pendant
cinq heures la protection de l'enfance
dans mon département et de façon
générale c'est un personnel qui est
toujours à flux tendu et qui est
toujours en grande difficulté est donc
faux dit en passant je salue le travail
merci madame berthet oui monsieur le
président je vous remercie simplement
monsieur ministre pour pour revenir sur
deux points effectivement dans mon
département de la savoie que je préside
la commission cohésion sociale et
enfance famille nous avons deux points
de préoccupation
tout d'abord le maintien dans la
scolarité effectivement vous en parliez
tout à l'heure des enfants confiés à la
ze et bien sûr le besoin de soins des
jeunes qui nous sont confiés ce que l'on
peut constater en effet c'est que
lorsque les enfants intègrent la
zoophilie a très souvent un
désengagement des autres accompagnant
d'autre part jouer revenir également sur
les liens et les croisements entre
certaines politiques certains voler des
plants pauvreté et les politiques de
protection de l'enfance et le besoin de
coordination entre ces deux politiques
et de façon générale quelle coordination
entre tous les dispositifs et plan
concernés notamment au niveau de
l'éducation nationale de la santé de la
justice on a parlé aussi le ministère de
l'intérieur
quels sont les articulations et les
coordinations qui vont être mises en
place pour vraiment un recoupement de
énormément de secteur merci c'est on a
fait trois avants ont continué d'accord
donc non moins donc monsieur mouillé
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais revenir beaucoup de
soin d'évoquer mais je voudrais quand
même revenir sous l'angle financier des
politiques publiques que vous menez
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
concertation beaucoup d'études de
rapport on voit bien que d'une façon
générale tous les pans de la politique
de cette politique soit aujourd'hui en
souffrance en matière de moyens que ce
soit en matière de formation des
professionnels les besoins de de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance on a parlé des
maynats les difficultés de moyens et de
mobilisation des professionnels pour les
centres de repérage en matière de
handicap
on a parlé de la pédopsychiatrie ou les
moyens supplémentaires qui ont été
annoncés aujourd'hui couvre à peine les
déficits des structures dont globalement
ne sont pas des moyens supplémentaires
enfin on est globalement dans une
situation extrêmement difficile et
tendue sans évoquer également les grands
enjeux en matière de coordination comme
ça a été évoqué juste avant
voilà donc moi ma qu'ils soient est très
simple c'est que au delà du discours
très technique vous proposer au-delà des
enjeux de réflexion d'étude et de
mobilisation au-delà de contractilité
département et au passage leur monde et
50 % de financement
ma question est quelles sont les menaces
suplémentaires vous souhaitez mettre en
place ne me souvenais d'accord que on
peut trouver déficience autour des
politiques déjà engagés merci monsieur
touraine merci monsieur le président
c'est ma faute c'est de ma faute mais
j'avais placé beaucoup trop d'espoirs
dans l'audition d'aujourd'hui je me
disais que vous alliez nous annoncer un
certain nombre de mesures de portée
générale et qui aurait amélioré la
situation que nous connaissons dans
notre pays avec une augmentation de la
pauvreté avec une augmentation de la
violence et ce n'est pas sans relation
avec la situation des de l'enfance et la
situation des jeunes dans notre dans
notre pays
or je reconnais les efforts que vous
faites
je reconnais vos ambitions
mais je suis obligé de constater que ce
que vous proposez en phase d ambition
paraît complètement dérisoire
les mesures que vous mettez en place
comme par unité par unité de millions
par unité d'enfants par unité de
pédopsychiatres on a soulevé tout à
l'heure le manque de pédopsychiatres ils
ont été divisés par deux en l'espace de
dix ans à ma connaissance il ya quatorze
départements qui n'en n'ont pas alors ce
que vous nous annoncez n'est pas de
nature à régler véritablement le
problème et à permettre que ça
fonctionne beaucoup mieux
il faut plus de il faut plus d'un an
pour opter pour être accueilli à un
enfant un enfant difficultés pour être
accueillant cmp alors c'est vrai que
vous annoncez un certain nombre de
mesures
c'est vrai que vous avez pris conscience
de la nécessité de faire mieux pour
autant ça ne va pas véritablement
changer les choses
et puis la grande ambition c'est
peut-être celle qui viendra avec les
1000 jours
mais la grande ambition c'est tout de
même de faire cesser cette situation de
la france qui est la vice championne du
monde en matière de déterminisme social
c'est pas votre faute
bien entendu c'est une longue succession
de manque véritablement mais on
n'apporte pas de solution il n'y a pas
eu de véritable réflexion sur ce point
et d'ambition annoncé et j'ai peur que
on continue longtemps comme ça avoir
augmenté dans des proportions
extrêmement importante
la violence dans notre pays les
frustrations la révolte puis deuxième
point vous avez vous avez évoqué le
terme de partenariat
il est beau le mot partenariat il est
beau il est plein de promesses
il est la certitude qu'on va avoir des
échanges à parts égales entre ceux qui
sont concernés
mais vous avez cité l'exemple du plan
pauvreté comme un modèle mais le plan
pauvreté monsieur le ministre c'est même
pas 150 millions d'euros qui ont été
affectés au département pour lutter
contre la pauvreté
c'est sans commune mesure avec l'enjeu
alors on n'embarque que les départements
dans des dépenses supplémentaires
considérables et on leur apporte 150
millions d'euros
vous apportez 80 millions d'euros on a
cité tout à l'heure des chiffres pour le
département d'ille-et-vilaine que j'ai
présidé pendant quelque temps ça
représente ça représentait quand je suis
parti 140 millions d'euros sur dix ans
mais il ya peut-être des économies
possibles il faudrait peut-être
peut-être regarder si cet argent est
bien dépensé
mais depuis des années vous imposer au
département de n'augmenter leurs
dépenses que de 1,2 pour cent y compris
dans les départements qui augmente de
population alors vous croyez
oui je vais être court mais je vous dis
un peu mon sentiment un peu de révolte
sur le manque de moyens que vous
apportez sur ce département vous croyez
qu'ils n'ont pas fait toutes les
économies nécessaires croyez qu'ils sont
pas en train de creuser ils sont jusqu'à
l'os
dans la plupart des politiques et ils
voudraient pouvoir faire mieux et vous
allez leur dire maintenant il faut que
vous fassiez encore davantage que vous
revaloriser les assistants familiaux que
vous améliorer l'encadrement à
l'intérieur des établissements et tout
ça qu'est ce que vous allez apporter sur
les maynats et ce sera mon dernier mot
mais je crois qu il
il résume un peu tout la position qui
est la vôtre vous avez dit mais ils sont
traités comme les autres venant de
l'état mais dans les départements ils
sont traités comme les autres
très exactement comme les autres il ya
pas de différence et ils sont accueillis
dans les mêmes conditions avec les mêmes
coûts que ça peut représenter seulement
le problème monsieur le ministre c'est
leur augmentation qui n'arrête pas et
les les départements vous avez dit
chacun doit prendre rendez-vous et que
ses responsabilités mais la
responsabilité de l'immigration de la
signature du droit international de
l'enfance c'est pas les départements
c'est l'état qui n'apportent que cinq
jours deux et cinq jours véritablement
réduit en matière d'indemnisation
merci après monsieur toile monsieur
théophile les disparités entre les
territoires laisse entrevoir un travail
considérable dans les autres mers où les
enfants sont moins bien protégés que
dans l'hexagone c'est un peu quelques
éléments de l'insee est autre que nous
avons et qui nous fondent à dire cela
vous avait précédemment indiqué que la
stratégie nationale de prévention et de
protection de l'enfance et ce qu'ils ont
ralliée avec la trajectoire
5.0 mené par annick girardin la ministre
notamment pour réaliser 0 exclusion des
sociétés inclusives luttant contre
toutes formes d'exclusion
pouvez vous nous préciser comment s
imbriquent rond ces deux stratégies
puisque la froid comment vous envisagez
cela et puis la stratégie nationale de
prévention et de protection de l'enfant
sera mise en oeuvre par le biais d'une
contractualisation avec les départements
vous avait dévoilé les 30 premiers
départements sélectionné vous avez
déclaré vouloir investir massivement
dans les départements qui ont plus
besoin mais également privilégier les
projets les plus aboutis
c'est ça qui me dire qui m'intéressent
pouvez vous nous indiquer plus
précisément notamment dans la
prospective de la prochaine vague de
contractualisation quels critères ont
été retenus pour réaliser cette
sélection
merci je vais continuer à mettre dans
les caraïbes avec madame jasmin d'accord
même jasmin et après j'aurais très bien
monsieur le président on me voyez
monsieur le ministre je voudrais
également vous faire part des
difficultés de relationnel je dirai où
la note d'information entre les
différentes
les départements les cas et les communes
particulièrement les ccas qui sont
quelquefois impliqués seulement dans les
situations critiques
or vous avez parlé des relations avec
les collectivités
donc il a été vice présidente de cette
science c'est seulement dans les
situations critiques que nous avons
constaté qu'il y avait notamment sur le
territoire des familles d'accueil qui
rencontraient des difficultés avec des
enfants difficiles
donc je crois qu'il faudrait améliorer
les relations et surtout l'information
d'autre part l'hébergement dans des
hôtels
l'alien est question ici dans l'hexagone
un peu plus ici dans l'hexagone que dans
nos départements
mais c'est un problème lié à
l'efficience parce que comment expliquer
que vous baissez les ap 1
et que des familles se retrouvent en
très grande difficulté est hébergée
quelques fois dans les hôtels est ce
qu'il ne serait pas plus pertinent
d'anticiper pour éviter justement que
les ce que ces familles et que des
enfants mineurs quelquefois non
accompagnés se retrouvent dans ces
centres est la dernière chose c'est
aussi pourrait vous impulsez et susciter
chez les associations mais dans les
communes
l'organisation des colonies de vacances
parce que très souvent les enfants dans
les périodes où il ya les vacances
scolaires se retrouvent ceux livrés à
eux mêmes donc je crois que permettre à
des associations et financée évidemment
les projets accompagnés tout au moins
pour la prise en charge des enfants
serait quand même une bonne chose
merci madame richet sur les psychologues
ou c'est la logique en tout cas vous
êtes là c'est la logique de
l'expérimentation que j'évoquais dans le
cas de l'article 51 tout à l'heure sur
le parcours de soins des enfants de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance où
effectivement on mobilise sa tombe de
professionnels libéraux dont des
psychologues et qui sont prises en
charge par la sécurité sociale
donc c'est pas exact enfin oui ça
participe de la même philosophie me
semble-t-il que celle que vous évoquez
on expérimente on a expérimenté donc
dans trois départements en étant à 10
cette année il vient des recettes
supplémentaires qui n'ont pas encore été
désigné sauf erreur non voilà c'est en
cours appel à candidatures et ça procède
de cette logique oui c'est une c des
négociations collectives qu'on lance en
le 27 février prochain pour les
assistantes familiales il ya quatre
chapitres qui sont mis sur la table à
négociations les conditions d'emploi
donc c'est tout ce qui est articulation
entre agrément formation et recrutement
les passerelles vers d'autres formations
deuxième j'habite c'est le soutien
professionnel
donc la question de l'intégration nous
essayons familiaux au sein des équipes
éducatives coordination relais et les
relais d'assistants familiaux les la
question
permanence téléphonique l'action les
équipes mobiles puisque vous l'évoquez
vous avez été assez normal évoqué
effectivement les familles d'accueil
sont aussi confrontés à des enfants
enfin pour vous parler avec des familles
d'accueil qui font ça depuis 20-30 ans
elles vous disent que les enfants ne
sont plus les mêmes
donc là on revient à notre il faut là
aussi qu'est des équipes mobiles enfin
des solutions des solutions de répit de
relais des équipes mobiles qui puisse
intervenir parce qu'elles sont pas
formées elles ne seront jamais formé de
toutes façons pour faire face à un
certain de situations trop complexe qui
relèvent d'autres choses
troisième sujet les conditions
matérielles donc rémy née